40 and 20 record best in the american
league and clinch their first division
title since 2010. please turn your
attention to left center field for the
unveiling of the 2020 american league
east championship banner the race
outlasted the astros to clinch the
american league pennant and move on to
their second world series in franchise
history
please turn your attention to left
center field once again for the
unveiling of the 2020 american league
championship banner
ladies and gentlemen your 2020 american
league champion tampa bay
rays
the starting pitcher rich hill will be
making his second start of the season
this young season for the raise
and he comes back to get him swinging
fell behind 3-1 goes 3-2 and then has
him out in front dwayne this may be the
best rich hill curve ball in his short
stint as a race starter that right there
is as good as it gets well that lineup
for the rays gonna face better and corey
kluber finishing up his warm-up tosses
the one start on the year year four
innings he did walk three in that outing
not like corey kluber
oh it punches him out on a pitch that
was clearly inside
but kluber will take it one away
now when he grounds to lemay there's one
on to first it's a double play
five four three
and the rays are down in the first no
runs to hit nobody left on base let's go
to the second inning
there's a cut and a miss
and another one two three innings
fast ball away
three two
strike three loud down
looking ground ball right side
wade can't get there diaz is going to
dig for third there'll be a throw and it
is not in time loose but not far enough
to give wendell the chance to move up
and the range have been on the corners
here's william
the raise with a chance here in the
bottom of the second to break out in
front
[Applause]
high fly ball back into right field
fragrance gonna go back he's at the
track at the wall it's off the wall
extra bases diaz scores linda will go to
third it's a double for adamas and the
rays lead one nothing
tell you what dwayne watch the swing
again by adamus we talked about austin
meadows going the other way on purpose
william thomas got a pitch that was
eleven all he was trying to do was hit
the ball in the air get the run in
brett phillips
phillips
lifts it into center field
hicks lines up to catch it wendell tags
he's headed to the plate the throw will
be cut off
the run scores and the rays lead two to
nothing
as a strike
he gets frazier looking
good
with their triple a club there's a swing
and miss
back-to-back strikeouts here
he gets talkman
rips one into left center field that's
gonna be a base hit over the head of
phillips bouncing up and over the wall a
bad break for the yankees because now
wade has to go back to third if it hit
the wall and bounce back onto the field
of play wade scores easily but a double
for le mayhew
and it's chopped that way and through
for base hit one run scores here comes
lemayo he will score it's a two run
single for stanton and the game is tied
at two
so the yankees with that hit erased
their defensive miscues
we're tied to two be a one-two to hicks
swung on and hit in the air to left
field and deep it is high head as far
it is gone it is a two run home run
hicks
hits one to the sticks a two run blast
four runs are in in the inning and the
yankees promptly take a 4-2 lead
and a shot into right that's going to
want to hop the wall
he'll make the turn and hold there and
so with another chance yoshi comes up
with a base hit
2-2
ground ball right side base hit
sugo is going to be waved home no play
on him over to third
goes meadows
frazier showed a double pumped out there
and the rays pick up a run and admit on
the corners
runner takes off pitches high don't
throw
rosarina picking up his first stolen
base of the year and now the rays have
two men in scoring position boy and
there was absolutely no play to be made
there
a rose arena with a great jump
did he go
yes he did
lau strikes out a big out
for kluber and the yankees
climb all back into left cockman was in
he'll have to go back it's over his hand
meadows scores hero terrain is going to
head to the plate it's a double for
wendell and the rays grab the lead
joey wendell comes through driving in
two
hits 5-4 tampa
bay how about having the car having to
let you know where to go and there's
strike three on the outside edge
just got it on the corner one away
two a swing and a
he takes care of frazier fastballed at
89 that time five four range with two
things i would say uh here we go
yeah that's going to be a big fit
zenino had to hold to see if it was
going to carry or not rodney rodney held
somebody that doesn't happen very often
i guess nobody out so it does the trick
we're certainly happy to have stu
sternberg join us the principal owner of
the raise
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
are you able to see the replay at all
yeah i'm looking up at it now okay
perfect break it down force that
big it stayed down stay down
down and the left field has been having
some issues today he running some bad
routes but he wasn't getting to that
regardless but he's kept his head down
on the ball and lowered it fooled
earlier enough some change ups but he
stayed down on that one and drove it the
other way look at that it's not even
that hard stu just crushed it i'm just
learning from you that's all that was
good that's all the ba terminology right
there there you go
[Applause]
look at that here's diaz the basically
rodney
[Applause]
a lot of good things happen when we take
the ball to the opposite field a little
wobbly in the box
and a swing and a miss pumped it up to
89 there and got the fastball by well
that's what you do you get him out in
front with the slower breaking ball from
a different arm slot and then 89 you're
able to just i mean this is middle plate
towering fly ball
right field all the way to the wall
gone
homerun to right center for anomalous
willie makes it 10-4 with his first home
run of the year in opposite field shot
fly ball deep left center going back
meadows on the track at the wall sia
home run dj le mayhew
it is his first of the year and it's now
10-5 tampa bay
[Applause]
gets him out of ground ball to short
adamus with the throw to first dugout
over there by diaz and the rays win it
it's a 10-5 win for the raise over the
new york yankees in their home opener